So I'm not seeing anything that says, you
know, create new workflow. So, what should I do?
>> So, the new rule button is actually
creating a new workflow. And what that means, when
it says new rule, is you're going to set up
a set of criteria that'll cause this to happen.
>> Okay, a trigger basically.
>> It's basically, there's another thing in Salesforce called a
trigger, which is what I'm trying to steer away from.
>> Okay.
>> But. A trigger is just a workflow made
of code.
>> Okay.
>> So, what we're doing right is
we're creating a situation that will only fire
when a certain set of criteria is made. And that's why it's called a rule.
>> Okay.
>> And so in this case, let's say this
is going to be on the maintenance ticket object
because it's going to be when a maintenance ticket
is created. That's when we're going to fire this rule.
>> So, Maintenance Ticket, Next. All right. So I guess I'll call the
rule Alert Technician.
>> 'Kay.
>> And I want to evaluate the rule when
the record is, what does this mean, evaluate the rule?
>> So, it's only going to run this rule When you,
>> The rule means the work flow, the series of steps?
>> The work flow, exactly. So in this case, what we're going to
eventually do is send an email and a task to a technician. But
this is asking, when should we do that? Should we do that every
time a maintenance ticket is created? Every time it's created and every time
it's edited? Or, every time it's created
And it meets this rule criteria down there.
>> It's edited but it's edited in a certain way.
>> If it didn't meet the criteria first, and then
it meets this rule criteria after it's been edited, fire it.
>> Gotcha, gotcha.
>> So, in this case, I think we would want the last, the last of the
three. Which is, every time it's created and
if it's edited to then meet this Criteria.
>> Like I wouldn't want to send an email. Or try to send an email
if the technician didn't have a valid email address or something like that.
>> Yeah.
>> Alright, so I'm going to run the rules of following criteria are
met. So the technician has an email address. Is what I'm going for.
>> Right.
>> Okay. So, I see maintenance ticket
technician, but I really want the email field.
>> Yup.
>> But I don't see that here. Is that, should I just click technician, or
what am I doing wrong?